يحاول الاحتلال العسكري ان يستحوذ على
البيوت وان يحل شعبه مكان الاصليين عندما
يهدم منزل بمعنه تهجير عندما لا يسمح
باعطاء تراخيص بناء هو عمليه تهجير عندما
يصادر ارض هي عمليه
[موسيقى]
تهجير
منذ احتلاله المدينه عام 67 يحاول جاهدا
تغيير الديموغرافيا بالارقام باستقدام
المستوطنين من الشتات وتشتيت الفلسطينيين
حتى في ارضهم ضخ مزيد من المستوطنين انشاء
جمعيات استيطان للاستيطان داخل الاحياء
الفلسطينيه ولاست بكتل ضخمه في محيط القدس
حتى العام
2022 صادر الاحتلال
35% من شرقي القدس فيما احتجز 52% من
المساحه المتبقيه تحت بند الاراضي الخضراء
ولم يتبقى للسكان العربي سوى
13% من مجمل المساحه كما هدم الاحتلال ما
يزيد على 20 ال بيت وقام بسحب اقامات
لاكثر من
14700 فلسطيني وعينها على عام 2005
حينها ووفق تصوراتهم وامانيه ستكون القدس
مدينه يهوديه تقطنها اقليه عربيه مشروع
القدس
5800 لعام
2050 يهدف لاستكمال تغيير الملامح
الديمغرافيه للمدينه بترحيل عشرات
التجمعات الفلسطينيه خارج القدس واحلال
الاف المستوطنين مكانهم مما يشكل استهدافا
واضحا لهويه المدينه ماذا عن المجتمع
الدولي اين هو من كل هذا هذا الامر غير
قانوني حسب القانون الدولي عمليه الضم هي
غير مقبوله عندما يتعلق الامر بالقدس
وفلسطين بصفه عامه المشكله لا تتعلق بغياب
الاحكام الدوليه او غياب الوضوح المساله
تكمن في غياب الاراده
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
دونها الروح يقول الفلسطينيون فلا سلام
ولا كلام ولا تفاوض دون
[موسيقى]
القدس